the way the tick tock algorithm works is  they're taking  bets on what you're going to be watching  as a user  this is very similar to how youtube's  algorithm works and how spotify's  algorithm works they're going to serve  you content in hopes that you click on  it  and tick tock wants to see that you're  going to actually be watching that video  the whole way through  it's going to start off with showing  your video to 100 people if those people  like comment engage or just even watch  the content the whole way through  they're going to be showing that to more  people they're then going to show it to  a thousand people and then slowly that  video is going to go viral  and you can see here with my tick-tock  views  it goes down and tik-tok is testing  different audiences and then once it  hits an  audience cap the video drops again and  they're constantly testing out  these new audiences to see who's going  to engage and who isn't